You collapse on the couch after work
completely drained. But here's the
thing. You didn't dig ditches. You sat
in a chair all day. Your brain treats
every email notification like a tiny
tiger attack. You're being hunted by
predators all day. Except that predators
are calendar invites. Think about it.
You check email every 6 minutes, but
your brain needs 23 minutes to refocus.
You're literally never fully focused.
And that exhaustion you feel, it's
happening at the cellular level. But
here's the silver lining. If these
factors multiply for bad, they multiply
for good, too. Want to know exactly why
you're drained and how to fix it? Watch
the full video.